deemed me worthy of the honor of
representing them I thought I could make
a difference here in making our
community our great country
and the world a better place for
generations to come
I like so many of my colleagues ran for
office because I believed that our
political system was broken controlled
by the powerful and the wealthy ignoring
and failing the regular people that it's
supposed to serve I came here to give a
voice to the unheard in the halls of
power I wanted to show young people
queer people working people imperfect
people that they belong here because
this is the people's house I fell short
of that and I'm sorry too every young
person who saw themselves and their
dreams reflected in me I'm sorry to
those who felt like I gave them hope in
one of the darkest times in our nation's
history I'm sorry to my family my
friends my staff my colleagues my
mentors to everyone who has supported
and believed in me I'm sorry to the
thousands of people who spent hours
knocking doors in the hot Summer Sun who
made countless phone calls who
sacrificed more than I could ever know
to give everything they could in every
possible way so that I could be here I
am so so sorry
and to every little girl who looked up
to me I hope that one day you can
forgive me the mistakes I made and the
people I've hurt that led to this moment
will haunt me for the rest of my life
and I have to come to terms with that
ever since those images first came out I
barely left my bed I've ignored all the
calls in the text and went to the
darkest places that a mine can go and
I've shed more tears than I thought were
possible I've hidden from the world
because I'm terrified of facing the
people that I let down but I made it
through because the people who love me
most dragged me back into the light and
reminded me that I was stronger than
that to those of you who were by my side
in my worst moments you know who you are
I love you I'm so grateful and I will
never forget
and I'm here today because so many of
the people I let down people close to me
supporters colleagues people have you
never even met told me to stand back up
and that despite all of my faults they
still believed in me and they were still
counting on me and I realized that
hiding away and disappearing would be
the one unforgivable sin I will never
shirk my responsibility for this sudden
ending to my time here but I have to say
more because this is bigger than me I am
leaving now because of a double standard
I'm leaving because I no longer want to
be used as a bargaining chip I'm leaving
because I didn't want to be peddled by
papers and blogs and websites used by
shameless operatives for the dirtiest
gutter politics that I've ever seen and
the right-wing media to drive clicks and
expand their audience by distributing
intimate photos of me taken without my
knowledge let alone my consent for the
sexual entertainment of millions I'm
leaving because of a misogynistic
culture that gleefully consumed my naked
pictures capitalized on my sexuality and
enabled my abusive ex to continue that
abuse this time with the entire country
watching I am leaving
because of the thousands of vile
threatening emails calls and texts that
made me fear for my life and the lives
of the people that I care about today is
the first time I've left my apartment
since the photos taken without my
consent were released and I'm scared I'm
leaving because for the sake of my
community my staff my family and myself
I can't allow this to continue because
I've been told that people were angry
when I stood strong after the first
article was posted and that they had
hundreds more photos and text messages
that they would release bit by bit until
they broke me down to nothing while they
used my faults and my past to distract
from the things that matter most I'm
leaving because there is only one
investigation that deserves the
attention of this country and that's the
one that we voted on today today I ask
you all to stand with me and commit to
creating a future where this no longer
happens to women and girls yes
I'm stepping down but I refuse to let
this experience scare off other women
who dare to take risks who dare to step
into this light who dare to be powerful
it might feel like they won in the short
term but they can't in the long term we
cannot let them the way to overcome this
setback is for women to keep showing up
to keep running for office to keep
stepping up as leaders because the more
we show up the less power they have I'm
leaving but we have men who have been
credibly accused of intentional acts of
sexual violence and remain in boardrooms
on the Supreme Court in this very body
and worst of all in the Oval Office so
the fight goes on to create the change
that every woman and girl in this
country deserves here in the halls of
Congress the fight will go on without me
and I trust so many of my colleagues to
be strong on this front
well I move on to one of the many other
battlefields because we have an entire
culture that has to change and we see it
in stark clarity today the forces of
revenge by a bitter jealous man
cyber exploitation and sexual shaming
that target our gender and a large
segment of society that fears and hates
powerful women have combined to push a
young woman out of power and say that
she doesn't belong here yet a man who
brags about his sexual predation who's
had dozens of women come forward to
accuse him of sexual assault who pushes
policies that are uniquely harmful to
women and who has filled the courts with
judges who proudly rule to deprive women
of the most fundamental rights to
control their own bodies sits in the
highest office of the land and so today
as my last vote I voted on impeachment
proceedings not just because of
corruption obstruction of justice or
gross misconduct but because of the
deepest abuse of power including the
abuse of power over women today as my
final act I voted to move forward with
the impeachment of Donald Trump on
behalf of the women of the United States
of America we will not stand down
will not be broken we will not be
silenced we will rise and we will they
make tomorrow better than today thank
you and I yield the balance of my time
for now but not forever